a shooting at a Waffle House prompts
some of the worst arguments for gun
control ever Americans cannot take a
joke about anything and Kanye 2020 is
launching and I could not be more
excited I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
[Music]
so on rare occasions there's a there's a
an event that happens in American public
life that unleashes all of the stupid
and yesterday indeed it turns out was
that event there's a shooting in a
Waffle House and there's a guy who's
incredibly heroic we're gonna talk about
all of it as well as the left reaction
to it because the left reaction is just
fully crazy like fully stupid and crazy
but before I get to any of that first I
want to say thanks to our sponsors over
at stamps.com so these days you can get
practically everything on demand this
podcast can get on demand you can get
movies on demand well there's a reason
you should be able to also get posted
John's a man with stamps.com with
stamps.com you can access all of the
amazing services of the post office
right from your desk 24/7 when it's
convenient for you we use stamps calm
here at the daily wear offices on a
regular basis because we don't have time
to send folks down to the post office
instead they can sit at their desk they
can print exact postage they can stick
it on the packages and they are good to
go you buy and print official US postage
for any letter any package using your
own computer and printer and the mail
carrier picks it up just click print
mail and you are done again we use it
here at the offices and we do so for a
reason right now use Shapiro when you go
to stamps.com and you get a special
offer $55 a free postage a digital scale
and a four week trial so pretty solid
deal just for using our promo code
Shapiro with the special offer over at
stamps.com again go to stamps calm
before you do anything else click on the
radio microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in Shapiro that stamps
comm enter promo code Shapiro for that
special deal there is a reason why so
many businesses use stamps comm
including we here at the Daily wire so
check it up stand check it out
stamps.com promo code Shapiro alrighty
so the big news yesterday is that there
was a an awful shooting at a Waffle
House in Nashville Tennessee Chris
Enslow over at the blaze reports and he
says local and federal law enforcement
turns out knew the man who opened fire
at a Tennessee Waffle House early Sunday
morning killing four and injuring at
least seven others they knew him so well
that he was arrested last year and had
his firearms confiscated so you might
ask why was this person walking naked
into a Waffle House and shooting people
how did he get his firearms well I have
the answer for you the Secret Service
said Sunday its agents arrested the
killer in July 2016 after he was found
in a restricted area near the White
House according to the Tennessee and so
it wasn't just that he was arrested he
was arrested by the Secret Service near
the White House because what the hell K
Secret Service representative Todd
Hudson
said he wanted to set up a meeting with
the president which it turns out is not
the way to set up the meeting with the
president
like really III know how to set up a
meeting with the president you don't do
it by walking up to the White House and
saying you want to set a meeting with
the president that hasn't been true
since like 1860 the killer who's
reportedly from Illinois there was a
revoked of his ability to possess
firearms following his arrest in
Washington Illinois police also
confiscated for firearms from his
possession including the ar-15 he used
in Sunday's killing a spokesman for the
National Police said Tazewell County
Sheriff Robert hustin explained at a
news conference that when the sheriff's
deputies came to confiscate the killer's
firearms last August his dad was present
and asked the officers if he could take
possession of the firearms instead
today's well said the father was legally
able to possess weapons in the state of
Illinois so they turned the weapons over
to him which it turns out was a terrible
decision because daddy then gave the
guns back to son so he should go to
prison for criminal negligence no
question about it
authorities say the killers father later
returned the firearms to his son however
is not immediately known if there was a
Tennessee law that prohibited the killer
from possessing the firearm so in other
words the cops knew about him they took
his gun away and then they returned his
guns to the father and the father gave
the guns to the son I don't know what
law on the books would prevent any of
this really because it's criminal
negligence for the father to have given
the guns to the Son and the son was
already not only barred from having the
gun but had had his guns taken away from
him now it's amazing about this is that
there was a an amazing American here
named James Shaw jr. who was present at
the Waffle House and as this shooting
went on he decided to charge the shooter
the shooter had an ar-15 he charged the
shooter anyway so here is James Shaw jr.
speaking about this publicly when he
proceeded to come in
I actually went behind his like a push
door swivel door and he shot through
that door I'm pretty sure and I'm pretty
sure he grazed my arm and it was at that
time that I kind of made up my mind
because there's no way to lock that door
that if it was gonna come down to it he
was gonna have to work to work to kill
me so at the time that he was either
reloading or the gun jammed or whatever
happened is when I ran through the the
Swivl door I hit him with the Swivl door
and then the get the gun was kind of
jammed up and it was pushed down so we
were scuffling
I managed to get him with one hand on
the gun and they're not grabbed it from
him
not threw it over the countertop and
then after that I was trying to get out
the door and I think he was pretty much
in the entranceway so I just took him
out with me out of the entrance and all
the way outside now that dudes an
American Hero I mean that is an
incredible thing right to charge a guy
with the ar-15 take the gun away from
him and stop the shooting is an amazing
thing obviously is wearing the bandages
on his hands because he burned his hands
because he grabbed the red-hot barrel of
the of the ar-15 which had been firing
he also I believe was grazed by a bullet
in the arm is what it was what it looked
like and he is he's fine he then he went
afterward with his family to church to
pray so amazing amazing dude now you
might say well this is a story of an
American Hero stopping a person when he
had no resources to do so because this
guy is just a hero and you might say you
know it would've been even better is if
this guide had a gun on him because then
presumably this guy would walk in with
the ar-15 taking the first shot and you
know this guy this hero right here would
have done something about it right this
is the kind of guy who'd have pulled out
his gun and shot the bad guy hope maybe
even saved a couple of more lives right
you might think there wouldn't better if
this fellow
James Shaw had actually had a gun you
would be wrong according to the left so
the left comes up with legitimately the
stupidest possible arguments I have ever
seen
like an insane number of stupid
arguments have arisen from this because
now the left is making the claim that
because James Shaw jr. was not armed
then now we should expect people to
disarm people with guns now this is a
little bit different from the argument
that was being made just a few weeks ago
with regard to ar-15s they can't expect
an armed school security officer to
charge a person with a gun and if you
have a pistol that you shouldn't be able
to shoot somebody within an hour 15
right they were saying the narrow 15 is
so wildly powerful that you shouldn't be
able to take down that shooter even if
you have a gun now they're saying that
everyone should be unarmed to take down
the shooter or something okay I'm gonna
show you a series of some of the dumbest
arguments you have ever seen I mean this
is really insane even folks on the Left
who are in favor of gun control should
recognize how stupid these arguments are
and stay away from them as much as
possible if you actually want to win the
argument so here is David Axelrod David
Axelrod was of course one of the lead
advisors campaign advisors to President
Trump and then he was in the White House
is was he chief of staff I chief
strategist for the White House under
Obama and here is what he tweeted out
quote with yet another mass shooting
today let us give full recognition to
Colt the manufacturer of the AR
semi-automatic rifle used in this
massacre for designing such an efficient
weapon for mass destruction for
commercial use so this is a really
really bad arguments the argument that
he's making here is that the
manufacturer is somehow responsible for
the person using the gun to kill people
which is weird because I tweeted back to
david axelrod full props to the makers
of the m4 for generating the firearms
used to kill Osama bin Laden no props to
President Obama right President Obama
made the call and all we heard about in
2012 was Obama that Osama bin Laden is
dead and Detroit is alive and they took
credit for the killing of Osama bin
Laden according David Axelrod it's the
gun manufacturer who really gets the
credit for the killing of anyone right
if anyone is killed it's the gun
manufacturer who's responsible for that
so presumably is the gun manufacturer
that gets to take credit for the Osama
bin Laden kill and not Barack Obama
seemed to have it Axl rotten not agree
with that logic but instead he is saying
such stupid things about gun
manufacturers this is why you know you
hear this myth that's put out there by
the left that there is some sort of
loophole for gun manufacturers when it
comes to liability if someone gets shot
you can't sue the gun manufacturer that
there's some sort of legal loophole that
has been enshrined into law no products
liability is a well-developed area of
anglo-american common law and products
liability suggests that there are a few
types of liability one is if you design
a product that is inherently dangerous
and then that product goes off in the
inherently dangerous way then you are
responsible for its for its danger but
rifles are designed to do what they do
and people buy them to do what they do
so there is no failure in design there's
no design flaw when it comes to product
manufacturing in the ar-15 and there's
also no manufacturing flaw which would
be like you buy a product and then it
breaks on you right there's no
manufacturing flaw so when people say
that a gun the gun manufacturer should
be able to be sued they are able to be
sued if you bought a gun and the gun
were to backfire on you and hurt you for
example you could sue the gun
manufacturer for a products
manufacturing claim or if the gun we're
so inherently dangerous and had a hair
trigger and you pick up the gun and it
just goes off because that's the way it
was designed then you have a design flaw
you get sued the gun company for that
but you can't sue the gun company for
making a gun that is perfectly
manufactured to specification any more
than you can sue a knife
company for making a night that is
perfectly manufactured to specification
you can't you can't sue you know the
Ginsu knife company because it cuts
things that's not the way that this
works but again blaming gun
manufacturers for the evil of individual
human beings it makes no more sense than
failing to credit heroes for the
individual heroism of human beings one
thing that we should all learn from
James Shaw by the way this is what folks
say in law enforcement is that if you
are in a mass shooting scenario then
charging the shooter sometimes is the
best thing that you can do obviously not
everybody is is given that kind of
courage either by God or has developed
it themselves
James Shaw jr. is one of the people who
has developed it good for him so other
stupid arguments a bunch of the of the
students from Parkland started making
the same argument and this was an
intensely intensely stupid argument and
the gonzalez tweeted out the local
police say a man at the scene rest
wrestled his gun away looks like you
don't need to arm a teacher or a
resource officer to stop a shooting
there goes the sales pitch for Smith
Wesson um
no so the argument I guess is that if
you have a guy who's super brave and who
runs into the face of fire and grabs a
gun from someone else no one needs a gun
so I guess we should disarm the police
Matt Walsh had a great reply to this he
said I saw a man eating spaghetti with
his hands the other day that means that
no one should have a fork like what is
it what like because so I guess the
solution is the law-abiding people
should not have guns but non law-abiding
people who have guns we should stop them
because we should run in there with our
magical bulletproof chests and then
somehow stop them this line of argument
was repeated ad infinitum yesterday it
was crazy I mean I was seeing it all
over the internet yesterday it wasn't
just Emma Gonzales David Hogg also
tweeted this out the insufferable
parkland survivor who says that everyone
who disagrees with him is an evil Pig he
says so only a good guy with a gun can
stop a bad guy with a gun and then he
tweeted at the NRA this had fifty six
thousand likes 56 thousand likes no-one
said only a good guy with a gun can stop
a bad guy with a gun okay what we did
say is that there is a much better shot
that you are going to stop a bad guy
with the gun with a gun then you are
charging the guy you know how many like
I would like to see statistically
speaking how many people who have
actually tried to charge a shooter ended
up being shot I'll bet you the numbers
pretty high
I'll bet you the number is pretty high
and then it didn't stop with him Seth
MacFarlane the the dope who makes Family
Guy he tweet out hero James Shaw a good
guy without a gun who stopped
that guy with a gun again I don't know
what you're trying to argue here are you
trying to argue that it's bad for good
people to have guns and I promise you if
James Shaw had a gun he would have used
it in far better fashion than he was
even able to use his body this is such a
dumb argument we'll talk a little bit
more about the dumb arguments and left
on gun control in just a second but
first I want to say thanks to our
sponsor is over at policy genius so 71%
of human beings say they need life
insurance they're only 59% of Americans
have coverage which means at least 12%
of americans are procrastinating and
procrastinating normally is a bad thing
it's really bad when if you drop dead
you leave your family bereft right we
actually know somebody this happened to
policy genius is the easiest way to
prevent that from happening you go
online you compare life insurance prices
you can compare quotes in just five
minutes when it's that easy putting it
off becomes a lot harder you can compare
quotes while sitting on the couch
watching TV you can compare quotes while
listening to this podcast policy genius
has helped over 4 million people shop
for insurance in place over 20 billion
dollars in coverage and then I've been
very focused on getting life insurance
for myself my wife has life insurance as
well if you are an adult if you have a
family there's no excuse for you not to
have life insurance and when it's this
easy there certainly is no excuse go
over to policy genius.com
again I know it's more but to think
about your own death it's even more more
but to think what happens to your family
if God forbid something happens to you
go to policy genius calm and by the way
they don't just do life insurance they
also do disability insurance and
renter's insurance and health insurance
if you care about it they can cover it
policy genius.com
when it's this easy to compare life
insurance why put it off policy
genius.com go and check it out you
really owe it to your family to do so ok
so one of the parts about the gun debate
that is so annoying is that whenever
there's an incident people instead of
looking at the facts of the incident
then drawing conclusions they
immediately rush to their various sides
of the aisle to back up whatever
narrative they think is supported by all
of this so the right looks at this story
and what the right says is okay I'm
gonna look at the facts of the case here
are the facts of the case the facts of
the case are that this shooter had his
guns taken away and then got his guns
back so don't blame us blame law
enforcement don't blame law-abiding
citizens like me you who have a I have a
9-millimeter handgun and I have a
shotgun you're gonna take away my guns
because the police couldn't take away
somebody else's how does that even
logical so the police couldn't protect
me but I need to be disarmed how does
that work and then beyond that we look
at the case with with James Shaw and we
say listen that guy's a hero but you
know it'd be better it would be better
to lower the bird
the entry for heroism so don't mean by
that is that there are certain obstacles
to being a heroic person right then one
of those obstacles is risk so to be a
heroic person means to undergo a certain
level of risk in order to do something
good but people are willing to undergo
lower levels of risk and higher levels
of risk James Shaw was somebody who was
willing to go undergo ultimate risk in
order to do something that needed to be
done disarming the shooter in this
particular case most people might be
cowering in the back hoping the shooter
would leave but that's because the
burden is really high right charging a
guy with a gun is a pretty high burden
and this is true in military service -
right asking people to do Pickett's
Charge is a different thing from asking
them to go into a well-planned operation
it requires a different level of risk
assessment and and willingness to
undergo risk in order to follow a
particular order well that's why the
best planners in the military spend
their time trying to figure out ways
where people have to undergo less risk
you are lowering the threshold of entry
for heroism well one of the things that
lowers the threshold for entry for
heroism is lowering the risk and one of
the things that lowers the risk is
having a gun to shoot a bad guy then how
many folks in that diner we're willing
to charge the guy probably lower than
the number of people in the diner who if
they had guns would have been willing to
shoot the guy I assume everybody in
there would have figured okay the risk
to me of pulling out my gun and shooting
this guy is pretty low right because now
I have a gun and he has a gun it's
certainly a lot lower than the risk of
me charging the guy but the left once
the risks to be as high as possible
apparently when faced with a mass
shooter and this is a serious problem
it's a serious problem it's also one of
the reasons why so many Americans look
at the left and they say you guys just
want to take our guns and so people on
the left are constantly saying no we
don't want to take your guns what are
you even talking about we're not
interested in taking your guns like why
would we do that what where's the
evidence the evidence is that you think
that the ultimate great situation is
what happened to James Shaw as opposed
to this is an outlier situation where a
hero was able to charge a guy with a gun
and succeed and I don't want everybody
to have to charge a guy with a gun
I would prefer very much for those
people to be able to shoot that guy that
does not seem unreasonable to me
but speaking of unreasonable I now want
to turn to the fact that everyone in
America has apparently lost their mind
with regard to the capacity to take even
mild criticism or joking it's a pretty
amazing thing it really is pretty
amazing so this is so speaking of people
who can't take a joke about guns jay
Feely is a
I believe kicker right I think he was a
kicker in the NFL for the Philadelphia
Eagles for years and he was yeah he was
a kicker that's right and and jay Feely
tweeted out this photo okay the he
tweeted out a photo of himself with his
daughter it was apparently a beautiful
blonde girl and her date to the prom
right who's just a you know a normal
looking dude who looks like a couple of
former employees here and he is an inch
a few leaves standing between them with
his arm around his daughter and in a
what looks like a Glock in the other
hand he's got a pistol in the other hand
and then it says wishing my beautiful
daughter on her date a great time at
prom hashtag bad boys has had 133
thousand likes hey this is the oldest
joke in America it's the oldest joke
okay this joke has been done a thousand
times I remember when I was in law
school there was a Halloween party and
some and a couple showed up as a shotgun
wedding right this is the oldest joke is
that if you hurt my daughter I will hurt
you and yet people lost their minds over
this people went crazy over this people
that how dare jay Feely how could jay
Feely do something like that
look at him he's threatening that man
with a gun first of all if you look at
the picture it's pretty clear that this
kid is not really be feeling very
threatened right he's smiling the second
of all it's a joke my goodness my
favorite response this was from the
feminist loren Zucca who can always be
counted on for the hottest feminist take
she said oh good another picture of a
man showing that he thinks his daughter
is his property so number one my
daughter does not have free reign over
her own life until she becomes an adult
and it's capable of making adult
decisions but that's really not what
this photo is showing okay like right
now my daughter is effectively speaking
my property because she is four what I
mean by that is I get to control her
life but she does not have all the
freedom that she would have if she were
an adult grown human being but in this
case the daughter is 17
probably at 16 or 17 years old but
that's not what the joke is
yeah idiots the joke is if you hurt my
daughter they will never find the body
that's the joke here but men acting like
men is now being seen as something
wildly toxic even when men are just
joking about acting like men I found a
great insight about this yesterday was
from a guy named neon taster he said you
know the entire left talks about the the
evils of rape culture so they say all
rape culture
so people saying that rape is okay so
evil father tweets out photo saying if
you hurt my daughter I'll kill you
father is the bad guy again folks we
need more fathers who are like this not
fewer okay we need more fathers who are
joking half joking about the fact that
if you hurt their daughters they will do
something really really nasty to you it
is good for men to protect women does
anyone really think jay Feely is gonna
like go shoot this guy I get this if his
daughter and this guy go have consensual
sex that J field lose in a break in the
room guns a-blazing is that really what
anybody thinks of course nobody thinks
that of course nobody thinks that but
the left has to think that because the
idea from the left is that the gun
inherently makes jay Feely a bad guy
they don't know jay Feely from adam but
they figure that if jay Feely is holding
a gun then he must be one of those
grunting Neanderthals who thinks that
his daughter is his property which is of
course insane there's a certain level of
cultural anger that exists on the left
toward people who are culturally on the
right I'm not even talking about people
who are politically on the right I'm
talking about people who for example own
a gun if you own a gun there are a lot
of expert my entire life living in Los
Angeles in Cambridge Massachusetts being
surrounded by people on the Left if you
say that you own a gun around people on
the left in Los Angeles or in Cambridge
Massachusetts they look at you as though
you are the kind of person who goes
hunting for boar with a spear and then
roasts it over an open flame before
taking your wife aaaghh back to your
cave like owning a gun is that sort of
cultural hollow mark to a lot of people
on the left and that's all that says
that's all this is because if the guy
had been standing there
right if jay Feely had been standing
there with say for example a noose right
and basically suggesting that he was
gonna come after this kid if something
happened to his daughter nobody would
have cared everybody thought okay funny
joke he's carrying a gun though and so
the idea is that the gun makes him super
aggressive and super scary and super
terrible how dare jay Feely that scary
scary scary man guns are not inherently
scary except if you train kids the guns
are inherently scary now it's possible
to train kids that guns are inherently
dangerous which they are okay but it is
also possible to train kids the guns are
a tool in the hands of the people who
wield them but the left doesn't see it
that way the gun in Jay feeley's hand
made jay Feely evil the gun in the hands
of the guy in tennessee he made the guy
in Tennessee evil it's not the guy in
Tennessee is evil and had a gun or the
guy in Tennessee was mentally ill and
had a gun when the jay Feely is a fine
law-abiding citizen and he had to go
and so it's a completely different story
and meanwhile speaking of cultural
intolerance of Shania Twain has been
raked over the coals because Shania
Twain had made the the awful awful awful
mistake of suggesting that she might
actually that you might actually go
ahead and vote she's Canadian that she
might have voted for Trump I'll explain
to you in just a second but first I want
to say thanks to our sponsors over at
helix sleep so there is nobody on the
planet who is just like you which is a
good thing because I mean like come on
but why would you buy a mattress suited
to somebody else hey you want to sleep
well at night you need helix sleep
mattresses I'm not saying that it's
gonna relieve all your sleep problems
but I'm gonna say that whatever sleep
problems you are having with the
mattress helix sleep will go a long way
toward resolving those working with the
world's leading sleep experts helix
sleep has developed a mattress that is
customized to your specific height
weight and sleep preferences so you can
have the best sleep of your life at an
unbeatable price here is how it works
you go to helix sleep calm you fill out
there two minutes sleep quiz and they'll
design your custom mattress they can
even customize each side for you and a
partner in 2018 helix sleep has even
taken customized sleep to the next level
with the helix pillow the only pillows
are fully adjustable so you can achieve
perfect comfort regardless of sleep
position or body type helix sleep has
thousands of five-star reviews plus you
get a hundred nights and try them out
it's really cool it comes in the mail
you unpack it inflates right in front of
you cuz it's foam we took a more
expensive mattress in our room and moved
it out of our room and substituted helix
sleep mattress because our helix sleep
mattress is so good go to helix sleep
calm slash Ben right now get up to 125
bucks toward your mattress order that's
helix sleep calm slash Ben for up to a
hundred and twenty five dollars off your
mattress order helix sleep calm slash
Ben and again that is up to 125 bucks
off your mattress order check it out
there's a reason that helix sleep is
such a fast growing company and there's
a reason we use helix sleep in our home
not just because they're advertisers all
right so meanwhile speaking of people
who cannot take a joke this is an insane
thing so shun aya Twain what it was in
an interview red shoes in an interview
and here's what she said right isn't
interview at the Guardian she said quote
I would have voted for him because even
though he was offensive he seemed honest
do you want straight or polite not that
you shouldn't be able to have both if I
were voting I just don't want BS I would
have voted for a feeling that it was
transparent and politics has a
reputation of not being that right okay
so basically she said what everyone in
the United States felt which is that
President Trump was more authentic than
Hillary Clinton now vote for
Clint vote for Donald Trump you know
they're there a lot of questions about
how to vote in that last election cycle
but it is not really in question that
Trump is a more authentic human than
Hillary Clinton because it's it's it's
difficult to find any less authentic
human than Hillary Clinton
there are legitimately mannequins that
are more authentic than Hillary Clinton
they're robots on TV that are
significantly more authentic than
Hillary Clinton and not I'm not even
talking about the robots from you know
from from West world I'm talking about
like actual Rosie robots like from the
Jetsons are more authentic than Hillary
Clinton so this is not a particularly
controversial statement but she then had
to tweet out a four part apology
okay here's what she tweeted quote I'd
like to apologize to anybody I have
offended in a recent interview with The
Guardian relating to the American
president the question caught me off
guard as a Canadian I regret answering
this unexpected question without giving
my response more context so number one
first of all she is Canadian why is
anybody like upset with how a Canadian
would vote she can't even vote who cares
second of all it is the most Canadian
thing in the history of Canada that you
are Canadian cannot vote in America an
election you're asked about voting in
the election then you apologize to
Canadians about how you would have voted
in an election that's not in Canada
pretty Canadian stuff eh well here's
what she said I would like to apologize
to anybody I have offended in a recent
interview and she continued by saying
I'm passionately against discrimination
of any kind and hope it's clear from the
choices I have made and the people I
stand with that entitled any common
moral beliefs with the current president
okay and then she continued along these
lines and she said I was trying to
explain in response to a question about
the election and my limited
understanding was that the president
talked to a portion of America like an
accessible person they could relate to
as he was not a politician and she
concluded my answer was awkward but
certainly should not be taken as
representative of my values nor does it
mean I endorse him I make music to bring
people together my paths will always be
one of inclusivity as my history shows
so um again I'm not sure what's divisive
about her saying he was more authentic
than Hillary Clinton I would have voted
for him she's from Canada
she is from Canada but this is the world
we now live in where every controversy
has to be about President Trump
everything in the world is about
President Trump and it's a point of high
irritation to me because my view about
President Trump is that President Trump
is not that important a human being
right he's important because he's
President of the United States but as a
person you know worrying about every
little thing from does or says like I
think a lot of the stuff that he
is well I think mostly said I think a
lot of he's done is great I think a lot
of stuff he said is execrable but so
what you know he's the president I think
that about every president the idea that
everything has to be about Trump is just
an amazing amazing thing and the fact
that we take the word of celebrities so
seriously it's pretty crazy now I will
point this out
you know the entire left they went
insane when Moore Ingram on Fox News
suggested that LeBron James should shut
up and dribble right even though she
wrote a book called shut up and saying
about the Dixie Chicks in 2004 they went
nuts over Laura Ingraham how could Laura
Ingraham say such a thing to LeBron
James shut up and rebel I said at the
time listen I think it's kind of a you
know he can say whatever he wants
is he an expert on politics not really
that's really what Laura was saying I
think okay but the entire left said to
Shania Twain shut up and sing so how is
it I don't know how can hold those two
thoughts in mind at the same time you
can't eat that you can't say to LeBron
James shut up and dribble but you can't
say to Shania Twain shut up and sing
very weird and demonstrative
demonstrative again of the fact that
when it comes to the left
it's the silencing that is more
important than the reality now I will
say this the fact that we grants our
celebrities any sort of credibility on
politics in the first place is bizarre
and also the reason why we now have
celebrity politicians not only President
Trump but Hillary Clinton let's face it
was a celebrity politician hey Hillary
Clinton a have had more of a legal
background than President Trump but when
she ran for a senator of New York she'd
only been first lady of the United
States that seal that was not an elected
position she never held elected office
and she went directly to being senator
and then she went directly from that for
running for president so Hillary Clinton
was a celebrity politician - she was
George W Bush was a celebrity politician
hey because yes he was governor of Texas
but the only reason he was governor of
Texas is because his last name was Bush
now I think Bush was a much better
president and Hillary Clinton would have
been obviously I think Donald Trump is
is doing stuff that I never thought a
conservative would do in office and
that's great but the obsession of
Americans with celebrity is pretty gross
and it's not exclusive to the left so
the right likes to think about the left
that the left is really obsessed with
celebrity and there there's no question
that folks on the left think that folks
in Hollywood have some sort of greater
window on the human condition than
anywhere else it's the reason why they
take so seriously all of the people from
Hollywood and it's the reason why all
these Democratic politicians want to
have Lena Dunham speaking at the DNC
even though Lena Dunham is one of the
most off-putting human beings on God's
green earth but the right is not immune
to this
there is something to the human
condition that when someone is famous or
someone is rich that we somehow grant
them a halo effect is it's an actual
psychological thing Wade they called the
halo effect you grant them the the
credibility of believing that they are
good at everything so somebody is super
wealthy then we assume that they are
super-smart also or if someone is super
beautiful we assume that they are also
worth listening to on politics if
someone is really good with for example
astrophysics like Stephen Hawking this
means he must have important things to
say about politics and religion if
you're Einstein this means that you are
good at politics so Einstein was a
socialist you'll see people on the Left
say this all the time
Einstein one of the great geniuses of
all time who's also socialist in his
economic leanings so he was good at
science nobody said he's good at
economics right and I I assume that you
wouldn't have assumed you even have
Frederick Hayek do your physics for you
but because people are famous we then
grant them a certain level of
credibility on other issues so the
latest example of this is Kanye West so
believe it or not the right is now
resonating to Kanye West so Kanye I will
not say like can we remember back to
2005 when after Hurricane Katrina Kanye
West went out there and said the george
w bush had purposely targeted black
people with a hurricane that guy like
the guy who jumped on stage with taylor
swift and said i'ma let you finish that
one so now he's tweeting out deep
thoughts and the right is so excited
they're so excited because Kanye West is
tweeting out things that sound kind of
right-wing like he tweeted out that he
supports Candace Owens Candace Owens
nice gal I'm friendly with Candace
Candace is uh she wants to Charlie Kirk
over a turning point USA she's a black
conservative and Kanye West tweeted out
that he likes how she thinks and now he
tweets out we have freedom of speech but
not freedom of thought and then he also
tweeted this one out okay that's true I
think and then you tweet out the thought
police want to suppress freedom of
thought okay also true and then he also
tweeted out at one point that self
victimization isn't is a disease
agree agree with all of these things and
I'm looking forward to Kanye West
tweeting out facts don't care about your
feelings like I think it'll be great but
the right responded to Kanye West as
though it was an earth-shattering thing
and a big celebrity like Kanye West was
saying things that remotely conservative
it just demonstrates the rights
desperation to be taken seriously in the
in the sphere of pop culture I think
that the Roseanne the Roseanne ratings
are another Evan
this I think that the right wants to be
taken seriously they don't want to be
seen as bad evil people and the pop
culture decides who's seen as bad and
evil pop culture tells you stories and
the folks in pop culture decide who gets
to be portrayed as the villain and who
gets to portrayed as the hero so every
time somebody on the right is portrayed
as not the villain the right is willing
to take it
so if Roseann voted for Trump even if
she is Pro cross-dressing and Pro gay
marriage and pro promiscuity and
pro-abortion will go well you know what
at least she's treating us well so we
like Roseanne now we're doing the same
thing with Kanye West but I would just
warn folks on the right you know you can
be happy the Kanye West said something
that seems to be conservative but let's
not pretend the Kanye West is some sort
of genius okay I will use every
opportunity ever to play this clip this
is from Jimmy Kimmel show back when
Jimmy Kimmel show was not garbage he had
on Josh Groban and Josh Groban the
singer and Josh Groban saying some of
the best Kanye West's tweets here isn't
here's what that sounds like
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
you get all of your favorites these are
all sweet I would I played the whole
video exact I loved it so much but Kanye
West is not like a super intelligent
human being and he is certainly not
politically intelligent and so the right
resonating so anything anyone in pop
culture says because look that guy's
famous okay Kanye West tweeted out oh
he's treated out the other day self
victimization is a disease he has also
in the past tweeted out quote I hate
when I'm on a flight and I wake up with
a water bottle next to me like oh great
now I got to be responsible for this
water bottle okay hey this is a guy who
tweeted quote I specifically ordered
Persian rugs with my cherub imagery what
do I have to do to get a simple Persian
rug with cherub imagery or this one man
ninjas are kind of cool I just don't
know any personally how about this one
sometimes I push the door close button
on people running toward the elevator I
just need my own elevator sometimes my
sanctuary it's funny but um should he be
deciding tax policy probably not don't
you hate when people clap too loud in
the car it's like yo this is a closed
area clapping is way too loud like I
love this is an entire tweet storm my
favorite unit of measurement is a bleep
load like when people ask how many shoes
I got I tell them I got a bleep load of
shoes how much is a bleep load I'm
assuming it's much more than a piss load
Kanye West man this is what a genius I
let I just threw some kazoo on this B
board yeah this is the guy you're going
to for guidance in politics really
really folks and then we wonder why our
politics is so stupid because we are
stupid okay the answer is because we're
dumb yeah I'll cut right to the chase
we're all stupid okay so more on our
stupidity in just a second but first
we're gonna have to go over to Daily
wire comm and subscribe for $9.99 a
month you can get a subscription daily
we're calm when you do you get the rest
of this show live you also get the rest
of Andrew Clavin show live the rest of
Michael Knowles's show live we have all
sorts of awesome goodies that are coming
up for you I don't want to spoil whoo I
just did an interview with last week but
it's pretty awesome and we're gonna
start doing some long form of interviews
with extras attached so though those
will be available if your subscribers
who go over right now and subscribe we
have so many goodies coming
can't even I can't even tell you and I'm
not fibbing this time it's actually true
so check it out I also get the annual
subscription for $4.99 bucks you get
this you left this year's hot or cold
tumbler it will revivify you and refresh
you you'll become younger it is the
fountain of intellectual youth the
leftist chairs hot or cold tumbler get
that right now or listen for free later
at iTunes or YouTube but please
subscribe please listen review the leave
us our review it always helps we are the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast in the nation
okay now speaking of insane stupidity I
have to move on to this story from GQ so
nobody reads GQ anymore because why
would you read GQ right like I'm not
sure to have that many subscribers in
the first place they have a full list by
the editors of GQ of 21 books that you
should not read 21 books you should not
read so that's exciting because there
are lots of books that I think that you
should not read but the books that they
suggest like this is so stupid that it's
basically the SJW guide to books you
should burn and it's pretty incredible
so number one on their list is Lonesome
Dove by Larry McMurtry hey Larry
McMurtry is not on the right hey Larry
McMurtry I believe is the same guy
didn't he write Brokeback Mountain Larry
McMurtry I believe that's right I
believe that he wrote yeah that's right
he he wrote he wrote the screenplay No -
Brokeback Mountain so Larry McMurtry is
not exactly a right wing dude they say
you shouldn't read Lonesome Dove which
is just a story about two friends on the
Prairie basically and it says quote I
actually love Lonesome Dove but I'm
convinced that the cowboy mythos with
its rigid masculine emotional landscape
glorification of guns and destruction
and misogynistic generals is a major
factor in the degradation of America
rather than perpetuate this myth and
love for everyone but particularly
American men to read the mountain line
by Gene Stafford it's a wicked brilliant
dark book set largely on a ranch in
Colorado but it acts in many ways a
strong rebuttal to all the old toxic
Western stereotypes we need to explode
you mean the Western stereotypes about
people pioneering out into an area where
they had no protection in order to build
the rest of the United States
you mean that Western ethos you mean the
ethos of men protecting women that ethos
and not everything that happened the Old
West is good there's plenty that was bad
later this week I'm gonna recommend a
movie that's about a lot of the bad
stuff that happened in the West but
Lonesome Dove is not about those things
and you're stupid okay bottom line GQ
editors who are incredibly stupid they
say you shouldn't read The Catcher in
the Rye by JD Salinger okay and what
they say is that instead of reading The
Catcher in the Rye you should read a
book called Olivia the story of a
British teenage girl who sent to a
boarding school in France who falls in
love with a female teacher and it's
basically Lolita about with lesbians
okay and the guy who writes it is this
saying that you shouldn't read Catcher
in the Rye is guy who wrote call me by
your name which is
and lolita for gay guys so just very
very exciting stuff from GQ they said
they say you shouldn't read goodbye to
all that by Robert Graves which is a
book about graves his time in the
trenches during World War one it's a
great book
they say it's incredibly racist because
he includes samples of near
unintelligible essays produced by three
of his students mahmoud mohamed mahmoud
mohamed mahmoud mohamed mahmoud mahmoud
mohamed from his postwar stint as an
english instructor in cairo instead so
basically you should definitely not read
this book about world war 1 because it
was written by a guy who lived during
World War one and during World War one
people were more racist so we shouldn't
read anything from them so don't read
any old literature guys because if you
read old literature you might learn that
old people had bad racial stereotypes
and then you might want to fight against
those racial stereotypes by reading old
books that's bad they also say don't
read the Old Man and the sea they say
that you should not read let's see a
farewell to arms they really hate how
many way they're really angry with with
Hemingway they say you shouldn't read
blood meridian by Cormac McCarthy
I actually think blood meridian is
overrated but Cormac McCarthy's very
good writer they say you should not read
John Adams by David McCulloch do not
read John Adams do not do do not do it
instead you should read a history about
the assassination of President Garfield
okay
sure and then they say nine and ten
do not read The Adventures of
Huckleberry Finn by Mark Twain so they
really really hate Twain why the worst
crime committed by Adventures of
Huckleberry twin is that it makes
first-time Twain readers think Twain
wrote tedious meandering stories he did
as is evidenced by this his book of
tedious meandering stories but he also
heard a lot of richly entertaining
meandering stories that are not
constrained by the ham-fisted narration
of a fictional backcountry child or
suffuse with his sweaty imitation of a
slave talking sweaty imitation of a
slave talking what the hell are you even
talking about
okay The Adventures of The Adventures of
Huckleberry Finn is one of the great
works of American literature and it is
an anti-slavery tome you morons but
again history means nothing here I wanna
go through the rest of this list in just
a second so here here are some of the
other things I'm most I have to finish
what they say here about Huckleberry
Finn
they say read of Frederick Douglass his
first-hand account of slavery which is
equal parts shocking and heartbreaking
first of all I've recommended Frederick
Douglass but you don't have to ignore
Huckleberry Finn I love this they say
Mark Twain was a racist just read
aventures of Huckleberry Finn The
Adventures of Huckleberry
- is determined not to be a racist book
the whole point of the book is that
black slavery is an evil you idiots
hey they they recommend it and they're a
couple books they recommend that are
pretty good like the rise and fall of
the Third Reich by by William Schreiber
which I've recommended on the show but I
love this number twelve on their list of
books you definitely should not read is
the Bible you definitely should not read
the Bible they say the Holy Bible is
rated very highly by all the people who
supposedly live by it but who an
actuality have not read it okay so I
agree and not enough people have
actually read the Bible but they say
those who have read didn't know there
are some good parts but the overall it
is certainly not the finest thing that
man has ever produced oh you mean the
basis for all of Western civilization is
not the finest thing that man has ever
produced
there's no way to read Shakespeare
without knowing the Bible there is no
way to read the Declaration of
Independence without knowing the Bible
there's no way to read any modern
literature without knowing biblical
references there is no way to read
anything that Westerners have written
that has any importance you can't read
just AF ski you cannot read Tolstoy you
cannot read any Great Western literature
without reading the Bible even the stuff
that is directed against the Bible I
even can't read you know stuff that I
think is stupid crap at the left legs
like The Handmaid's Tale without
understanding the Bible he says those I
love this it is repetitive self
contradictory sententious foolish and
even at times ill-intentioned okay
editors of GQ I'm sure that you know
more than the rest of human history
combined instead they recommend that you
read a book called The Notebook no not
the one about like the two youngsters
who have sex but they're actually old
not that one the the something called a
Goethe Christoph a marvelous tale two
brothers who have to get along when
things get rough and I love this the
subtlety and cruelty of this story is
that is like that famous sword stroke
from below the boat that plunged upward
through the bowels the lungs and the
throat and into the brain of the rower
okay then all right
they say you shouldn't read Lord of the
Rings Lord of the Rings is really bad
because if you read Lord of the Rings
then you might know about things like
virtue that'd be bad also don't read
Dracula because Dracula is boring this
is not true by the way Dracula is
actually very not boring it's a really
good book it's anti-semitic right it
doesn't cut in favor of my folks but it
is not a bad book
catch-22 they say you shouldn't read I
love this I could never get into
catch-22 it fails to capture the
absurdities an impossible conflicts of
war what in the world are you talking
about the entire book is about the
absurdity of war the title of the book
is catch-22 it catch-22 is that if you
fly too many missions right if you if
you're capable of flying a lot of
missions then they put you up in the air
even if you've already fulfilled your
quota and if you don't fly enough
missions they won't let you out so they
make you fill more missions
that's what catch-22 is the whole thing
is about the absurdity of war you
numbskulls they say that you should not
read gravity's rainbow by Thomas Pynchon
you should instead read inherent vice by
Thomas Pynchon ok gravity's rainbow is
unreadable there is no question but
gravity's inherent vice is not a good
book ok so you're gonna read pinch and
go read crying of lot 49 they say
shouldn't read slaughterhouse-five by
Vonnegut you shouldn't read Gulliver's
Travels by Jonathan Swift you definitely
should not read that so some of the
great westerns some of the great
literature of the Western Canon you
should definitely not read but you
should read these obscure SJW books that
that they are recommending for you from
GQ so well done
GQ demonstrating once and for all the
intellectual scorn in which you hold the
great works of Western literature is
fully justified by the fact that you
write for a magazine nobody reads but
this does go to sort of the shallowness
of modern American culture is that
people believe that because they were
born now they are smarter than people
who were born 200 years ago I promise
you you weren't smarter than the people
who were born 200 years ago you're
standing on their achievements you're
running on the fumes of their value
system you're living in a free country
because of stuff that they did but don't
you know you you weren't born on third
base ok I mean you didn't hit triple you
were born on third base here
civilization really speaking everyone in
this civilization seems to think that
they hit a triple when they were born on
third base hey you live in a free
relatively crime free relatively
egalitarian society because of the
sacrifices made by legitimately millions
of people over the course of three
thousand years of human history and many
of those people were smarter than you
and there's weird belief that because
you have more information than they did
in some areas of life this means that
you are smarter on everything hey you're
not smarter on human nature which has
not changed in several thousand years
simply because you know more about how
the Hubble telescope works it's just an
idiotic argument knowing more science
doesn't mean knowing more about how
human beings operate and what makes
human beings human beings or knowing
what great literature is insight into
human nature is as old as time and as
deep as the thought of people who lived
long before you did okay so time for a
couple of things that I like and then
we'll do something
that I hate so the things that I like
the there's a book that I read over the
weekend that I really enjoyed it's a
book called two wings integrating faith
and reason from Ignatius press Ignatius
press the Catholic press and they prints
a lot of really interesting stuff I
really like what they what they do it's
by Brian Clayton and Douglas Cruz I
believe that Clayton just was on Andrew
Klavan show so he's just an interview
with withdrew so you should go check
that out over a Drew's channel on the
Andrew Clavin show but the book is
obviously yet titled well it's about
integrating faith and reason and it
really is kind of good simple logical
arguments for what faith is about what
reason is about where there's crossover
where there's not cross over and it's
intellectually honest I mean it will say
where there is no crossover between
faith and reason or where religion makes
assumptions that reason simply cannot
justify or where reason makes assumption
that reason can't justify it's it's I
think a really good beginner's guide to
the conflict between faith and reason
and where they unify and it's a good
attempt to put the pieces back together
a little bit so check that out - wings
integrating faith and reason pretty easy
read that's about 240 pages and and well
worth taking a look at so you should go
and check that out as well okay time for
some things that I hate so one of the
things that makes me absolutely nuts
about the state of modern politics is
again everything revolves around
president Trump even though in reality
President Trump is a guy in the Oval
Office who's trying to do a job
sometimes he does it well sometimes he
doesn't do it so well but because of
Trump everybody has now been forced to
take a position on the world as though
Trump is the prism from which all light
refracts and one of those people is bob
Corker bob Corker is the senator from
tennessee he's a lifelong republican and
bob Corker is now essentially refusing
to endorse his successor Marsha
Blackburn in Tennessee which means the
Republicans could lose the Senate if she
loses that seat in Tennessee but he
can't find a way to say something nice
about Marsha Blackburn because Marsha
Blackburn has been friendly to trump has
to be real about this most Republicans
are pretty friendly with Trump because
he's the president of the United States
bob Corker has a lot of distaste for
Trump that's fine that's his prerogative
but do not endorse the priorities that
that you spent your entire career
supposedly fighting for bob Corker
because you don't like Trump is
definitely cutting off your nose to
spite your face here's bob Corker
failing to defend Marsha Blackburn
data the rest of the story wasn't
written
during the interview I had the Christian
Science Monitor and and and first men of
Marsha Blackburn to say that she should
be elected just because she's going to
vote for Mitch McConnell well Danna you
know I'm supporting the nominee I've
worked with the nominee for some time
and and I don't know what else to say
not so much so much you know so much
virtue signaling because he knows he's
talking to Dana Bash on CNN as opposed
to being on Fox News and this is one of
the things that you can always notice
about politicians they do say different
things on different networks okay
speaking of people who are refracting
things through the prism of Trump
Elizabeth Warren is an amazing thing so
Elizabeth Warren has said that she has
Native American blood
she has Native American ancestry there's
no evidence to this in fact none zero
zip zilch her best defense is that her
grandmother apparently had high
cheekbones I'm not joking this is what
she has said and that she once wrote a
recipe for a cookbook called powwow Chow
again not kidding that's a thing she's
actually said Trump making fun of her
has called her Pocahontas that's not a
rip on Native Americans that syrup on
her for pretending to be a Native
American in the same way that people rip
on Shaun King because they think that
Shaun King has no evidence of actually
being black because on his birth
certificate his father is white and his
mother is white he's a making fun of
Shaun King is not racist making fun of
Shaun King is making fun of Shaun King
because Shaun King may not in fact be a
black person right according to people
who think this hey Elizabeth Warren is
not a Native American person buy any
evidence whatsoever and in Elizabeth
Warren because she's refracting
everything back through that lens of
Trump she gets to claim that Trump's
Pocahontas insult his races so she's not
a racist for claiming that she's Native
American Trump is racist for calling her
out on claiming that she's Native
American in it look and he's been told
over and over and over by tribal leaders
cut this out stop this this is racist
because it's a racist intent he's not
doing this to pay a compliment he's
doing it to get out there and that's
against them us against them us against
them in every possible wait
okay so again this is Justin the
pandering is so high you know it's
highbrow pandering here then again
because it's all about Trump and that
means that we have to ignore all the
crimes of
everybody else now listen this is not
what about ISM I think that again Trump
has had some stuff that I've been very
very critical on him about his tweets
are insanely stupid a large percentage
of the time but him calling her
Pocahontas is not racist her claiming to
be Native American without any evidence
in order to get ahead politically in
order to get a job at Harvard Law School
that seems to me a lot more a lot more
like hijacking somebody else's culture
than anything the President Trump has
done finally the final stupid thing is
Tom Perez who is the the head of the DNC
he says that we have seen a mountain of
evidence on Trump Russia collusion again
he can say this about Trump because
people are angry at Trump but there is
no evidence I mean really there's very
little evidence whatsoever on this I
believe in doing your homework and over
the course of the last year we have seen
I think a mountain of evidence of
collusion between the campaign and the
Russians to basically affect our
democracy okay so again if you have that
evidence you can show it any time it
just demonstrates that the Democrats
because they believe that all of life
revolves around Trump they will attempt
to impeach him if they do win back the
house even if they have no evidence to
support it because they will just claim
evidence and then hope enough people
hate Trump that they'll get away with it
okay so we ran out of time to do a
Federalist paper we will do one tomorrow
but we will be back here then I'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alexander Oh audio is mixed by
Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Joshua Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright floor publishing